jederzeit kann hier eine russische
rakete einschlagen tausende waren es in
den vergangenen tagen und wochen wir
sind unterwegs mit der ukrainischen
armee auf einer straße östlich von
ratgeb die front ist nicht weit entfernt
die ukrainischen soldaten wollen uns die
geländegewinne der vergangenen tage
zeigen die erfolge gegen die russen ein
video in den sozialen netzwerken zeigt
den abschuss eines modernen russischen
kampfpanzers vor vier tagen jetzt führen
die soldaten stolz das ausgebrannte
wrack vor
die jungs haben mitbekommen dass ein
konto auf der straße ist sie waren dort
hinten dann sind sie mit panzerfäusten
raus gerannt und haben ihnen den garaus
gemacht
ein paar kilometer weiter im kleinen
dorf molo dover dachten sie lange dass
ihnen die lebensmittel ausgehen doch
heute sind das erste mal seit wochen
wieder welche eingetroffen milchreis
mail
im kleinen laden versucht verkäuferin
natascha die nahrungsmittel gerecht
aufzuteilen
die not ist groß seit beginn des krieges
war motto war frontgebiet und
abgeschnitten von der außenwelt natascha
ist froh dass die kämpfe erst einmal
vorbei sind wir haben auch während der
kämpfe gearbeitet aber nicht vollzeit
wir hatten für zwei bis drei stunden
geöffnet die leute sind gekommen haben
eingekauft und dann mussten wir
schließen also denn die schlange nicht
mehr da war es dann sind die
kampfflugzeuge geflogen und wir sind
schnell nach hause gerannt ich hatte
solche angst
600 menschen haben hier vor dem krieg
gelebt jetzt ist die hälfte vor den
kämpfen geflohen wie viele genau weiß
niemand die russischen truppen sind
nicht weit entfernt zehn oder 20
kilometer vielleicht jeder hier fürchtet
sich vor einer rückkehr des feindes
sie fürchten um zu schlafen immer noch
im keller
seit kriegsbeginn ist molotova direkt an
der front jeden tag flogen von hier die
raketen richtung hf
77 tage geschützdonner gefechte
lebensgefahr
lange lag mode war sogar im niemandsland
zwischen den linien ende märz rückten
die russen ein um ihre geschütze noch
näher richtung stadt zu bringen frei
bewegen konnte sich dann niemand mehr
wir treffen wladimir er sitzt hier seit
kriegsbeginn fest der weg nach al kib
ist zu gefährlich
nur wer nach hause fahren konnte um
lebensmittel zu holen hat überhaupt
erfahren was passiert dass sie ist das
ende der welt
wie sagt man sich das ist der neutrale
streifen da sind weder die einen noch
die anderen
niemand kümmert sich um uns
bisher gab es kaum was zu essen
der 76 jährige ist auf dem weg zum
einzigen brunnen im dorf fließend wasser
gibt es in mode war schon seit wochen
nicht mehr jeden tag muss wladimir einen
kilometer zum wasserholen gehen am
brunnen treffen sich die die hier
geblieben sind der hass auf die russin
ist groß
ich möchte nicht nur dass die verjagt
ich möchte dass sie vernichtet werden
gott bewahre und schütze unsere soldaten
auf dem weg zurück nach krefeld unser
konvoi noch einmal an trümmer so weit
das auge reicht der presseoffizier will
uns zeigen dass der krieg hier noch vor
ein paar tagen in voller grausamkeit
gebrütet hat
[Musik]
eine fahrzeugkolonne mit zivilisten ist
hier vor vier tagen losgefahren sie
sollten evakuiert werden bei der anfahrt
zu dieser kreuzung auf dem hügel wurden
sie von einem panzer beschossen von dort
aus hat er auf diese autos geschossen
auf die zivilisten
es war ein volltreffer von einem panzer
natürlich hat das opfer gegeben in
berlin gibt
die ganze gegend wurde hart getroffen es
gibt hunderte tote zu beklagen
[Musik]
doch an hartz iv sind die russen vorerst
gescheitert die zweitgrößte stadt der
ukraine wurde nicht eingenommen sie war
seit beginn des krieges schwer umkämpft
wochenlang hatten die russen kharkiv tag
und nacht beschossen lebensgefahr für
zehntausende
doch seit tagen vermeldet die
ukrainische armee erfolge bei der
gegenoffensive dorf im dorf wird
zurückerobert eine atempause für die
ganze region doch niemand weiß für wie
lange es gibt gerüchte dass sich nur 80
kilometer entfernt bereits wieder
russische truppen sammeln für einen
neuen angriff auf die stadt
trotzdem erwacht dort gerade wieder das
leben heute sind am zweiten tag in folge
keine raketen auf die stadt geschossen
worden in diesen tagen ist das eine gute
nachricht
der metro war vor dem krieg webdesigner
jetzt hilft er mit anderen
ehrenamtlichen der initiative aktiv
zusammen dabei aufzuräumen ein stück
normalität wiederherzustellen
seine frau und seine kleine tochter sind
im westen des landes in sicherheit will
er sie bald wieder zu sich holen
nein im moment habe ich ihnen gesagt
dass sie noch etwas warten so klar
wollen sie unbedingt zurück kommen aber
wir schauen lieber mal wie sich die
ereignisse entwickeln und dann
entscheiden wir wie es weitergeht
aus aktiv sind hunderttausende geflohen
der metro wartet genau wie alle anderen
helfer darauf dass seine familie bald in
ihre stadt zurückkehren kann sie alle
hoffen dass ihre streitkräfte siegen
dass die russen nicht noch einmal
angreifen und dass die ständige
todesangst endlich aufhört